right so should we start with
introducing the pallet if you could say
your name and some of the films that
you've worked on that bin button on the
galaxy and I'm Lizzy we only Georgiou
and I did the hair and makeup sort of
make guardians of the galaxy
I'm Peterson's King and I'm here this
time for into the woods I'm Mike Ross I
received a BAFTA in the past for Orlando
and the Aviator I'm right Helland and
I'm here with Peter for into the woods
hi I'm Lisa Warner and I'm here for mr.
Tanner I'm John Sewell I did the hair
and makeup on that theory of everything
I have a BAFTA for many many years ago
French and Saunders and three other
nominations and we've got someone in the
floor as well so first of all let's talk
about creating a character do you tend
to visualize before you meet the actor
and actress how you want them to look or
is it conceived when you actually manage
to see the person for the first time
from my point of view on the particular
movie that we're dealing with some
information comes over from the States
it could be a concept design other times
we design and concept things ourselves
but as soon as it's not always done to
the spec so the actor might not
necessarily be there when they've done
the concepts so when the actor does turn
up it kind of changes things but in a
really good way you kind of really get
to grips with all the angles you're
dealing with and that's the fun part of
it because you kind of adapt it to work
exactly for yourselves and the out and
the artist getting making sure it's
flattering and it works for I mean you
know the studios will give you concept
art which is great and it's fine in it
but it's a somewhere to start yeah I
mean you know some people think oh
that's where you finish and it's like
well no that's where you start and then
when you meet the actor or actress
whatever you're then in discussion with
the with the artist with the door
rector with a lot of people I mean it's
collaborative always because in the end
the actors got to where the whatever
you're designing so it's you can't be
just a face company and say this is how
you're going to look by you know when
they have to have their inputs they have
to them feel comfortable in what they're
doing
so it is and also the relevance of when
they actually do tests and they have to
be with the other artists and how the
colors work with the other artists and
the different looks
yeah it all has to be complementary and
not clashing so there's a lot of
different factors that kind of I think
it also depends on whether a film is
period or whether it's fantasy or
whether it's a biopic yeah and where
your your creative process starts from
you know where you read your script when
you mark out and yeah as you say if it's
period then you start doing your
reference thing and so yeah it comes
from all yeah this it's always it's
never just the one thing it's always
everything and everyone has ideas and
move on but you know there to benefit in
that sense I have to make Eddie look
assume that's a Stephen Hawking so then
that's your other you know you know if
you've actually got to get pictures and
you've got to look at the person's face
and you've got to decide what you've got
to do is just put those little elements
in because you know you don't want it to
be sketchy looking like it you want it
it's just the essence and the elements
that make it that person I think it's
like that when you are doing biopics and
it's about someone who's still alive or
dead
it's that thing of where you want to go
and it's a decisions have to be made
like do we really want to try and make
him look as or Herbers much like the
person yeah or are we gonna go for the
essence of the character and we're not
gonna worry so much which I always
personally think is a much better way to
go because you know otherwise it does
get all both pathetic heavy and too much
exactly is that director led I mean with
would you kind of have to say actually
this might work better if it is more
about the essence of them rather than
trying to make them look exactly I think
you offer up everything yeah they choose
you offer whatever you can
then they decide what they like we don't
like isn't it yeah I remember when the
aviator and Martin Scorsese specifically
said or I I don't want it to be
look-alikes right and there were so many
famous people and I said but I do it was
exactly that thing capture the essence
of the person and you know obviously as
closely as you can but no prosthetics
nothing that was going to get in the
world yeah with Timothy Spall for mr.
Turner obviously that's a very key look
so you know just talk us through the
process from beginning to end really
with him and Christie use the hair and
makeup designer she usually does
surgeries with them with Mike she's very
involved from the beginning with Mike's
films obviously there are no studios I
mean it just is very much collaboration
but with mr. Turner it was it was
obviously we had you know it just
paintings and a general idea of what he
would look like and then there was just
a general decay throughout the film so
there are three different stages the
first stage of him kind of quite young
the middle stage of he's kind of like
declined there and the house also also
you know the house starts decaying and
Hannah starts the house mate starts
decaying and her skin condition
gradually gets worse and worse but I
mean it's very much a collaboration with
the actors because they obviously start
rehearsing many months up six months
before we've even started so I mean the
great thing we've you know it's a very
low-budget film about all the at all of
the actors were so brilliant all of the
the other artists that are in the film
that actually started growing their hair
since the when they were casting January
so by the time April came round where
these fantastic bids to work with you
know fantastic hair and we didn't need
to make any facial they were all very
much up they're all very much into their
character so I mean that's that is
no he's taking his artist on from what
I've heard from Chrissy once he's taken
these artists on they're on board but a
lot of the time when you're doing other
films and some low-budget films they're
doing another so when you kind of say
well can you leave your eyebrows to grow
because they I can't so a lot of the
time you're ending up and even painting
in little eyebrows are actually sticking
them on to actually make them look like
that period because they're you know
there's all these wonderful shaped
eyebrows now that everyone is having
sort of threaded and everything and then
you and then you're doing a lovely
Edwardian number or whatever it's not
going to work so you end up even having
to painting or you know apply little
tiny it's crazy it's 18th century on the
Gold Coast in Australia and all the
women it's like we've had to do quite a
few workshops and actually saying you
know because there's so many women it
you know when you start there's about
300 women it's like maybe every single
woman has a plot I really really thinly
plucked eyebrows it seems to be a big
disease over there and it's like well
how to do and do workshops or working
out how we can do it quickly and get rid
of them all because it looks crazy it
really does well know I've got all the
extras everything so I've made all my
own tooth in hours oh well so we could
just knock them back ever so slightly
boy he took us through Meryl Streep's
transformation in in two words
that's process well it it starts with
she and I months before we get the
script and we talk about where we're
gonna go what we're gonna do and what
we're not gonna do because we don't want
to repeat anything which is getting more
and more complicated but she wanted to
make sure that she looked like herself
and she was definite that she was going
to take advantage for the first time in
her life of her crooked nose so there
was nothing that's her and then she just
said let's do a forehead piece and a
chin and we got ahold of Matthew Smith
and he sculpted and put on these
fabulous pieces which took out her
eyebrows and and the long hands which he
he we tried a bunch of things and
realized that Merrill was either gonna
kill herself or everybody on the set
with them so they're just they're
silicone so that and then how to keep
them on so they became extensions
because just because you know you think
this is wonderful then when you're
really doing it you're acting these
things how many times in a flying finger
Runa take that did you know did you
final day the the cast had a because
then there was the transformation and so
then I had these beautiful blue nails
which exactly matched the dress thanks
to Peter's kit he just pulled it out and
I I did about ten or twelve sets I would
sit at night and file them and do and
paint them it's over and so on anyway
the cast would would see at the end of
the day who could collect the most nails
because they were flying all over the
set in the woods in the thing on the cow
in everybody's dresses and then they
tell you up who won the day I think
that's all we've got time for now thank
you to all our panelists that was
fantastic thank you
you
you